I thought Dolph Ziggler did better and
then he had to yeah he did he took it
really seriously like he does with all
of his you know we work on the road
together a lot and he he takes comedy
very seriously you guys we're gonna roll
together and now he'll open for me and
then we'll do a 30-minute Q&A at the end
so we're going to be able to use these
jokes at the end to like all the extra
ones that we didn't use on each other do
you have yeah do I have any yeah well I
was really excited for Jeff Ross to
finally be in a room with someone who's
broken more chairs he was a fan of the
burn and and we just kind of became
friends through there because we used to
live tweet the burn and we used to with
all these hashtags and then he would
chime in and I was like this guy's
really funny and then I ran into him
that new years at The Comedy Store and
then it was just like friends forever
yeah really before he was the champ yes
I know and last night I told him he
didn't have a belt and he was like I
mean I am the intercontinental he did
keep his clothes on and I must say I
wasn't as funny as he was I was hoping
for a little more wrestling showmanship
yes he came out so a little understated
I thought and I don't think I think that
worked against him he was a little bit
his first joke he really struggled you
could tell he wasn't used to the format
but then he went on a run like jokes 2
through 4 where he was just hitting home
runs left and right I was so impressed
about kicking me in the stomach so that
I could finally feel a kick in my
stomach so genius Sarah I didn't know
how intense this was gonna get I didn't
know if I'd have to bust out a super
kick but I mean I know when your act you
say a lot you know you're you're not
married you're getting down the line and
just I didn't want that to be the only
time you ever felt a kick
your stomach I was like I'm done I was
like I thought I'd lost just at that
point really yeah yeah just that joke
was yeah I did today the smartest joke
of the night I did feel a shift in the
crowd and the wave did do a big
wrestling move on that joke yeah one of
them got put through a table
[Applause]
yeah so what would you have felt if he
beat you that would have been
humiliating um no I mean I've lost the
Rose before when I got to a non comedian
once you've lost right and that was the
Mike Lawrence
yeah that's the only time I've ever lost
because I did when we were before it was
a show too in like 12 rounds or whatever
hey Trevor Wilson oh those back doors
overtime right pretty badass yeah we're
both like just so jolly and likable you
know you get nervous when you're
battling I'm not really nervous about
losing what I really want to impress the
person that I am roasting like I want
you to like the jokes so much you want
to use them in your act
oh I'm not worried I don't mind losing
as long as they're two jokes that I've
that I'm like I wish I'd written that
joke right and that's how I felt last
night so I would not have been upset
about losing at all so what you don't
use that you're using your act
oh the kicking one for sure really and
like how jealous I am that he gets to
come out and everybody looks at him in
the new walks down walk down the aisle
every week you have to watch me your
friend walk down the aisle while music
plays and everyone's looking at me and
there's a ring at the end
to be fair to be fair I get pinned by
big sweaty guys but I get paid millions
of dollars when you do it it's just for
like Waffle House and a ride home you
know what I loved is that he didn't do
any like jokes that people normally
do I thought they were really smart and
well-written and thought out and and him
and I talked about that a lot before
because I was he was just like the only
thing I ever hate is that people just
use jokes on girls and especially
knowing you like I know you're not like
that and it doesn't it we just didn't
want any of the jokes to be do you think
it was a trap
did you think that was a trap when you
know a lot you know about because he we
just both have a lot of respect for
roasting and comedy and we wanted it to
be smart and we wanted to both look like
we had really prepared and we did you
know so we were like finally battling
somebody prettier than you I kept seeing
coach T's turntables rise up thank you
for doing it yeah of course I was I was
so honored that you asked and I thought
Nikki and Anthony Anthony has a sweet
spot for you I'll tell you that he told
me he's voting for you no matter what
happened you Sarah Tiana looking as
beautiful as you ever have in the past
couple years
well that's great I was like really
worried I was like I was like I had a
joke prepared like of course you're
gonna vote for Dolph because you guys
are family well I mean Eskimo brothers
but it wasn't oh sorry to bring out it
was great and then but Nikki you know
I'm a huge fan of hers too and I was so
proud of her and happy for her in the
roast and and I just really look up to
her and her comedy I think it's really
smart and and I felt like you did like
like wow she just fit right into this
and like she I did not feel like she
held back I felt like everything she
that came out of natural and I felt like
she really held her own up there with
with you and and jazz and I was really
impressed with her to she's like that
sorority sister who's like join join
Kappa Kappa Gamma and then like forces
you to drink until you almost die laughs
yeah I asked you a question because I
know you're a big wrestling fan why do
you think wrestling fans are drawn to
roast battle so much because its
scripted about the competition
yeah and I think it's also like people
have their favorites going in and but
you can still be surprised and you could
turn on somebody just based on what they
do out there I think it's just healthy
fun competition it's exciting you never
know what's gonna happen and I think
that's yeah they're just
we're like fun competitive people but
not like right it's not mean-spirited
it's all in good fun and like the kids
can watch and most of us won't have
brain damage by 38 yeah fingers crossed
right shutout the Dolph Ziggler for
leaving his comfort zone of the WWE I
hope more wrestlers phonus up and hit up
Rose battle because that'd be fun yeah
yeah I agree and yeah it doesn't hurt as
much to put your body in the ice bucket
afterwards
[Applause]